And guys
Thank you for all the warm words - that was one of the hardest things for me
and getting started a long time ago in this it's just
accepting compliments and
Being in front it was it was 350 videos that I made before. I wasn't totally embarrassed by myself watching them back
I couldn't watch them back and 700 until I was actually inspired by myself
So it's still even like I love me in the 100 ons
I love doing the groups like this is a highlight for me coming to Boston
And I'm still getting used to taking the complements. And so thank you means a lot and it's great to be here
So I think your purpose comes from your pain as
Much as I love entrepreneurs and I think entrepreneurs are gonna solve all the world's major problems. I like to say it's not corporations
It's not the government like we're gonna do it. It's the problem with the world
We're gonna solve this what we do entrepreneurs as much as I leaned in on the positive
I think really the why what you do comes from pain
And I think people are good people in general. Like I think humans are good. I'm on team human
I think I think people are good
And when you have gone through something painful
you just naturally want to make it easier for other people who are suffering that same thing and
I think human nature is to try to avoid the pain forget the pain put it behind us. Never go back there
It's a terrible place where I think if you actually want to help people you need to run back into your pain
Understand what that meant to you and how how bad it was and then whatever you did to get over it then helping other people
Make the road a little bit easier. So for me entrepreneurship was really painful. I
Was making 300 hours a month my first company it was 19 I
Struggled a lot. I thought it would be hard but I didn't think it would be that hard
It was the lowest time of my life the worst
self-confidence
Feeling like I'm putting in so much effort and I'm getting zero results from it and I just felt
Kind of useless as a human being and I the worst day of my life was I told my business partner that I quit
and just cried my face off and
The next day got up and said I can't quit like I just I could deal with the failure
But I couldn't deal with not knowing and so I had to keep going
Eventually, it worked out we found strategies we talked about that. It's not this, you know, terrible story it worked out
It was great. But I still you know, I resonate more with the entrepreneur who's struggling and like
Can't afford to pay rent and there are a solo entrepreneur then then the people who have you know
The fancy cars and all that stuff
Even though we've had success in my business now and so I just want to make the road a little bit easier
I
Was too embarrassed and ashamed to tell my friends that I couldn't
I'd had no money and I couldn't hang out with them. I had to pick one thing a month
I'm making three hundred bucks a month, right? It's like
It sucks
and so I had to pick one thing in a week a month that I could do with my friends Pizza beer birthday party and
The rest were just telling them I'm living the entrepreneur life, you know too busy and hustling hard, you know
All the stuff that we say but really like I just couldn't afford to go out with them
and honestly the I'm sure they would have supported me and
We could have done something a lot cheaper or no cost just hanging out at somebody's house if I was just honest with them
But I was just too embarrassed and ashamed to say guys like I have no money. I can't you know
And so I just I try to make the content that I wish I had seen when I was 19 getting started
And my passion is still helping entrepreneurs
and so as much as I talk about the why so your question of I
Think entrepreneurs will do all the amazing things in the world. It's really born from the place if I suffered so much
Emotionally and personally to build this my own business that I just I know how hard it is to get started as an entrepreneur
I just want to make the road a little bit easier for the next people who are starting up building the muscle of
Stop caring of what other people think is super valuable
It took me a long time to figure that out and even today if I'm ever worried about what somebody might think of me
If that's the reason not to do it
Then I have to go and do it and it's not the not to
Show it in their face and say look how great I am. It's just for you. So
As an example. I remember being in in my hometown Toronto. We're here just for the weekend
Nina's have never been the boss in so I thought we'd bring her out and explore the city and
I'm ever in Toronto. I'd be walking to this busy intersection
And before I got there I'd be listening to music in my earbuds and I'd be on the streets side streets
And I'd be like groovin and jiving, you know, dancing to my song one word. Tony mosey. Yeah
And I get to the busy intersection and then I just I stopped
because there are other people there and
When I caught that I thought why am I playing small because of these people? I'm not offending them
I'm not trying to get in their face, but I just naturally play small because of the people are watching me
And so when I caught it, then I had the dents even bigger than I would normally right
I'm like dancing up a storm on the corner of a busy intersection in Toronto. You're in Shepherd of any you guys are local
And again, it's not to get in their face or say look at me it's just for me anytime I feel
The sense of I'm playing small because of fear of judgment then I have to go and do that thing
The thing for me is how many times did I go to that intersection and just play small and never catch it?
How many times did I have my earbuds on and dance and just stop dancing, but never notice it you know
Probably hundreds of times. And so when you catch it, then you have to go and do the thing
So whenever you like even here when when kids saying hey who wants to come up and talk about themselves?
You know the natural reactions that go my god. Don't pick me. Don't pick me. Don't pick me, right?
And so if you ever feel that if you can ever catch it, there's times are you're doing it automatically?
But if you ever catch it
that's not a good reason like it's better to come up here and totally suck and blank out and you've got
That's a friendly community. Right? Like there's no tomatoes that are going to be throwing at you
maybe people cheering you on if that's ever the reason to not do something because you're worried about
Looking stupid or how you're going to be judged then then you have to do it
Regardless of the outcome regardless of anybody, you know spies your book or downloads your app or goes to your website
Like that's not the point. It's not the promotion. It's you releasing that thing
So I slowly started building those muscles. I think we all have these big missions
we want to go off and change the world and make a big impact that our purpose comes from our pain and we want to
Help like entrepreneurs want to help
to do those big things you have to be able to take on a lot of
you know a lot of hate a lot of people who will criticize you and
how will you go off and take do that big thing if you can't even
Do a speech in front of here or dance big on the street corner
right, you go into the gym trying to lift like a thousand pounds when you can't even lift a five-pound dumbbell yet and
so the good news is you can train that and you can get better at it every
Single time and so just like as an encouraging message the next time you feel yourself playing small even today
Like if you are nervous about introducing yourself to somebody
Find the stranger and introduce yourself just because like it doesn't matter if they if they never go to your website or app
even if you lead off like oh
You know what?
I never introduce myself, and I'm just I just want to say hi. And then you walk away like that's enough
You just released it
and
So I think we by default play small because we're afraid of other people's opinions and judgments and the more that you can release at
In the faster, you can do it the more you're able to move forward and live the life that you want. I
think if you're just thinking about starting up
Just find a way to start. It's crazy. How many?
Excuses and we get stuck in planning mode and planning and planning come with the perfect plan
you just you got to just do something and I think a lot of the value that I try to bring to the people that
I hang out with whether they're micro-moments
Here or one-on-ones at the coffee shop
we just came from or look people that I even driving down from Boston with my team is
As soon as here's the thing when you're around me as soon as you say
I wish I could do this then we're finding a way to do that like right now right so
You know brahim my camera guy one of my camera guys some DP vault
On the way down. He's like yeah one day like I want to post a story on Instagram
But I don't know what to say and I wonder if I go live like how many people would show up, right?
It's like what we're doing both
We're driving down from Toronto. It's like 9 hours and and then he goes on like, you know
How many dudes like 18 stories and a 45-minute live stream is like now? He's hamming it up
It's like it wasn't that big a deal but just do it. What are you gonna say? It doesn't matter
Nobody's watching anyway
post the thing like what are you so afraid of
right
Well, I was driving he was doing his stories in the backseat and aim with switch legroom because I need you know
He's behind me. So I got long legs
Shawn here, you know he comes into the coffee shop. He just came from and
He comes in he says yeah one day I want to start I wanna start vlogging and he's like what what'd he do?
I'm a musician. Oh, cool. What do you do I rap you rap. Awesome, you know Tony's a rapper, too
Okay in this coffee shop, we're gonna do a rap
Right, and so we got my camera crew and and they did their own little freestyle rap in the coffee shop
Alright, I grab another guy and he's afraid of making stories
we went outside and we just made our first one-minute story like just just do the thing find a small way and just do the
thing that you want to do, it's
it's not that scary and even if it is like just by doing it you release it and you come back like
Why was that so terrifying?
Right and you should be way further ahead than then you are because you're just afraid
And because you get stuck in planning planning planning planning mode
You can't plan your way to success like plan is important but most of us are over planners
And I'm the same way like I plan so much and I learned it because I lost a 40 million dollar deal my first business
Because I over planned and didn't do enough doing and like that needs to change think that's not cool
So that's one thing that I always try to impart when I'm when I'm working with people's whatever vision you have
Whatever big dream like this what we're good at we love thinking about the dream and with the impact we want to have it's amazing
But just thinking about it's not gonna do anything. You got it you got to do
so what's the smallest possible way to get started and
Then just start building momentum. So if the answer is making YouTube videos great
Make youtube videos and put one up every day
Even if it sucks like the quantity will lead to the quality the more you do it the better you'll get
I'm sure when Tony started rapping it sucked and when he's heard of public speaking
He sucked right like like everything we've ever tried to do ever
Right, and it's just practice and getting better and put in the time in and momentum and we're just too afraid to start so
whatever your big dream is find some small way and just do it right now that that little
Bit of momentum is crazy. How far can take you you just get on a roll? So just start
How do you turn your pain into power in your fear into fuel? Yeah, it's a great question
one starting with
If you have the awareness from what your pain is so for me
I lean in so heavy on the positive and the optimism that I just blanked out
I don't remember the past failures in the negativity. So I had to do a lot of a lot of work to just uncover
What the pain was?
You might know it easily. Some people are more self aware. Like I wasn't it was a process for me
Once you have found it then
You need to see that it's easy to get lost in it
like putting yourself back if I put myself back in that position of when I told my business partner that I quit and
I just felt like a total failure as a human being that sucks thinking about that, right?
It's a really crappy place to be it's then just realizing that
Humans are built to serve
And if you're not happy right now with your life, then you're not serving enough. You're not helping other people enough
I think we're just we are built to serve. We want to help other people. I think it's part of our DNA
so, how does your pain then help serve others and
It's one of two ways. Either you either you dealt with and you got through it. So in my case, I
Solved the problem like I'm not I'm not struggling to get by as an entrepreneur anymore
so I can give
my story and my
Strategies and my tactics on how I did it because I know it worked for me and hopefully it worked for you guys
But maybe you haven't solved it yet. Like maybe you don't know what you're doing yet. Maybe you're still in the pain and
Even just sharing your journey of what you're trying to do to overcome the pain
Like if you're in that if you're in your pain right now and you want to get rid of it
That is an inspiration to the people
Because so many people are stuck in that zone and they have no way to get out and seeing you take the first path
Take the first step. Like I want to make your video great
just seeing you make a first video even if the video sucks like it's better if it's
And they see you do it gives them a shield. It gives them permission that they can go off and do it, too
So it's just thinking about what the pain is that you if you have it right away. You know it great
if not do some work to think about it and
then have you solved it and you can give strategies on how to do it or
Are you still working through it and it's not don't come off as an expert on something that you don't know what you're talking about
But your journey is still valuable important. I
Can I can hang out with entrepreneurs all day long? Like I'll go I'll forget to go to the bathroom. I'll forget to eat
You know, I'll stay up all night. Like it's just it fuels me
Because it's part of the struggle that I went through
if I look at something like
Obesity or depression? I think those are really like I think depression is super important to solve I
Can that's about all I can say about it? Cuz I've never gone through depression
So I can't authenticate Auk about it. I don't have strategies for you
I've never gone through it. But if you've gone through it and you've come out the other side then being willing to
Share the fact that you're dealing with this thing. I think that's like the biggest first step is here's what I'm so afraid of and
Show it to the world
right and in
the fear of judgment
Right. So like Sheila's got a business around
Make up and helping people who?
Who've lost a lot of weight and then have extra skin I had to deal with it
And she was inspired by the guy who?
Went shirtless and showed off all his extra skin like that takes an insane amount of bravery
This is like the thing that you are the most afraid of and you're saying hey world. Look at what I'm so afraid of
right
Be that guy for the thing you're afraid of
Because when people see that then they get inspired. It's like well if he could do it I could do it too and
they may not need to go on the website and like show off their extra skin, but a smaller step for them might just be
Asking a girl out
right like
Some small step and you gave them permission by you
Doing the thing that you're afraid to do you gave them permission to the thing that they're afraid to do, too
so recognizing that that thing that you're so afraid of is your strength because I can't talk about extra skin and
What you should do about it
right, but Sheila can and then I think I think if you can then you must
like I think if you can then you have the responsibility to
so it's my responsibility to help entrepreneurs I can therefore I must
Whatever that pain you went through you have to share it and it doesn't mean you have to drag down like maybe you you went
Through abuse and you're your dad hit you or something. You don't listen to me to drag your dad through the mud
Sometimes other people are involved in the story, but how can you tell the story without negatively impacting the people around you?
But I think it's your responsibility
And I think ultimately you'll feel just way better like you guys fuel me
Through these things through the comments in the YouTube channel, like I wake up every day knowing that the work that I do
Matters, and I'm not special if anything I'm like super less than special
Like 350 videos before I wasn't totally embarrassed. Most people quit after one or five right? I just kept going
And I think all of you could like whoever said video like I think you could I think you could crush me
Way faster, it's just cuz I have done 6,000 videos, right so like you
Better get better at something. If you've done it 6,000 times, right? It's hard not to
so yeah, I think I think figuring out your pain then recognizing that humans are built to serve and
You must it is your responsibility to give back and contribute and that will be your ultimate
Satisfaction happiness in life, too
You know, I don't know that changes as you as you grow or not
I think I think it's easy for everybody in this room to feel overwhelmed
Regardless of if I have you know, 20 people working for me or not, right? I
Think it starts with understanding yourself. So dissecting yourself and what you love doing
Jerry Seinfeld
Says you have to do the thing that other people would find torturous, but you love it
I'm sure if you stepped into my schedule you would feel overwhelmed immediately
But it's not because I'm great like if I jumped into your life I say this is ridiculous
I can't handle it like I'm overwhelmed after five minutes. And so it's just understanding the
way that you need to schedule your life and
Build to it. So I love being I love having a calendar. I love everything lined out. So Monday know what I'm doing Tuesday
I'm doing something Wednesday and then I like repeating my days. So example Tuesday is my YouTube day Tuesday
I'm I'm doing all the research I'm seeing what my team has come together
I'm filming videos and then I don't touch anything until next Tuesday and
So one it allows me to like be super productive on Tuesday making on my YouTube videos and then I I like to miss it
Right. I like I can't wait to go and film again right that I don't get it and again until Tuesday
right and that works for me like that may be
The worst advice ever for you, right?
but having the understanding of a schedule that works for you and then
Designing your life according to it and you may not be able to do it fully yet
Right like you might have a job you might have other responsibilities is that you're working your way through?
But if every month you're taking a little bit
Closer step you take a half hour an hour more every week
To start working on the thing that you're doing and spending less time than the stuff that you hate
According the schedule that you want. So it's how it's a difficult question ask because I don't live your life, right?
But I don't think it's any easier or difficult as you get
like I like I like people I
like I
Like the people on my team and I want them to grow as people
You know
Danny and brahim my two video guys and I where he MS some where he went to the washing good we can talk about him
While he's that in a good way
Their ultimate goal is to build like a Netflix special
They want to film
Content for Netflix, right?
And now they're doing like wedding photography and a bunch of stuff. And so this is a step it looked great
I want I want my thing to be a platform to help you
Give go get your Netflix special
Even if that means you're gonna leave me
If you're with me for six months or two years or whatever and then you're doing Netflix, like I'm so happy for you
we were we were scoping out his
His show on the way down like on the way down the Boston like Danny
What do you ultimately want to do?
I want to I want to make a I want to make like a two-hour video. I want to make a movie. Okay?
so, how do we
Like let's make it five minutes short like start what nobody's gonna say here?
Here's a million dollars gonna make it to our movie. Right? So let's make a five minutes short. What does that look like?
And it's like okay. I don't know how to crunch it down into five minutes because it's a big story great
Let's look we've got eight hours
You know, like let's work through it right tell me what the story is and we started working through it. I gave my perspective
I'm like, I can't tell him how to do his art, but just in breaking them down
We came up with a script that can work for him and just in
Like a half hour or 45 min the conversation. He's got enough to go off and build his five minutes short
I wake up this morning. I'm up til 3:30 last night
we wake up early cuz I'm
Always afraid that I'm gonna miss the alarm. So when I'm traveling I always end up waking super early. I got like no sleep
I had no sleep the night before the first thing I'm doing
Is finding spots for Danny to shoot his video because he wants to do an airplane
Thing and you can't go to an airport and shoot, but there's a spot in Toronto
Where the planes are flying over this gas station like you can go and film there and get the shot that he wants I got
To show him like a screen candle what that looks that's what I'm doing the first thing I know I'm in bed
Researching Google Images to find the spot so that when he wakes up is a gay need. Hey, look at this, right?
So, but that's me
Like I want the people on my team to win
For as long as they're with me and if they leave then I want them to leave and like go do your thing
So I
schedule my life and build my life and business as much as possible around the things that I love doing and I try to make
That happen. I think that's one of the greatest things that being entrepreneurs you can design the life and the business that you want
So it's really understanding. What is overwhelming in your life right now?
and what does an ideal schedule look like and then it's it's I'm not the like burn the boats guy and
Kill all your other responsibilities and just go all in and do it. I think you just if you have
Confidence that this is working like you have a plane like by the end of the year
I want to eliminate this and you work towards making to happen and it's solely your schedule becomes more and more
What you wanted to look like? I think if you know where you're gonna be in five years are thinking small I
Think idea that, you know the kind of person you need to be in five years means that you're not
Exploring and doing enough stuff to really figure yourself out
I think it's possible to work towards a five year goal
but I think if you hit that, I feel like you could have done way more if you were just
Open to life and reacting and changing along the way because you won't be the same person in five years as you are now
So I don't worry so much about having a five year goal
I think about life time the big thing that I'm trying to accomplish my big mission
That's never gonna happen. But I'm I'm everyday trying to make it a little tiny dent in it. And then just what am I doing?
Next what's coming up? Like when we doing for the next couple months and almost nothing in between?
I want to I want to solve the world's biggest problem. I think it's untapped human potential
I think people are doing the wrong thing. I think most people are just doing the wrong thing
I don't think most people wake up and
are
Just excited about life and are doing work that is meaningful to them
I think everybody has Michael Jordan level talent at something or Tom Brady level talent
At something I don't think Tom Brady is that special I don't think Tom Brady is the best football player of all time he's not
He's not the best the best quarterback of all time is a manager at Starbucks because he never picked up a football
That's how most people are living their life you have Tom Brady level talent at something
You're just not doing it I think that's most people
So I don't think that Tom Brady is special. I definitely don't think that I'm super special
I think everybody has that in them. They just don't even believe is my one where it's a they don't believe that they can
You know, I see something like cancer I think we should have really called I think we should have already solved cancer
I think I think I think the woman who will solve cancer is an accountant right now and
whether she knew that she should have taken biology and
Got held back or her parents told him not to do it, or she just never tried
It wasn't part of her awareness and now she's an accountant and she hates her life. You could have solved cancer, right?
That's how I see the world
So I think I think all of you have Tom I'm used to seeing Michael doing Tom Brady level talent at something
And so it's finding it and when you found it then believing in yourself enough to chase it every day and go be Tom Brady
How do I stay in flow and how do I plan the days when I'm not in flow?
I don't I don't think that we're in flow that often. I'm not even flow every day
And I think we fool ourselves a lot of times like I'm in flowing through these emails. Yeah, I'm really crushing this like, you know
That's yes
And so what I do is I
Have this and this works for me again, right? You got to figure out works for you
I have my schedule and I stick to my schedule
I know what I'm doing every
Day of the week and I'm pretty excited and pumped about that and we schedule in family stuff as much it was vigil everything else
in
But then when I mean when I really get going on something when I hit flow on something then I try to stay there as
Long as possible
I'll push almost everything possible aside to do that thing. So in example since my wife is here at the back I
I wanted to I decided while we're on a cruise in
September that I wanted to finish my second book on the anniversary date of my first book
So your one words my first book
top ten was a success is my second one and I decided
Took me like I don't know six months to write half the book because it was like picking away at it and I just decided
December 6. The book has to be out
And I was mid September. We're on a cruise ship. There's a lot of work that has to get done
I had to finish writing half of it and then proofread
You know artwork everything it's crazy. So it meant that by the end of the cruise. I had to finish the book
So I told Nina
Nina I need to finish my book
and
You know while Nina was sleeping. I was working my book. Well, Nina was working at it
I was working on my book
We still went to the ports and the cruises stops, and we did our stuff and then every extra moment
I was working on my book and
I never do that
Like I don't I have a cellphone, but I don't have a cell phone number
because when I'm with
Nina I'm with Nina, you can't call me
Right
So I
Really value my family time
but I was in the zone and I had to finish that and
She understood and the only reason why she understood is because I already had so much
I mean she can come up and talk about it. But in my words I
Had enough in the emotional bank account if that was our life every single week
We wouldn't be together. Right like she would have she would have dumped me because I don't spent any time with her
but that's how I see the world and that whenever I get in the flow on something I
Try to stay there for as long as possible and push everything off for as long as possible
Even though it means short-term
Sacrifices in some other area of my life for business because what I'm gonna create in that moment is gonna be gold
it's gonna be gold when you aren't flowing you're creating like it will be gold so I will stay up until
My eyes are burning and I will push meetings and apologize and I know what can make it up to people
Because I need to stay there, but I'm not there that often
Right, that's not a deal and maybe a just maybe I just suck like great, but for me, I'm not there that often
So for the days that I'm not there I have my schedule
So I'm not waking up I say what am I gonna do today? I don't know
Let me wait for my flow and I don't know it's like explore and do something, right?
So that that's but that's me like I don't want to force what I do on you
But that's the way that I think about it is when I'm inflating to see you there for as long as absolutely possible and push
Everything as much as possible and then for everything else I scheduled designed the life that I want and that works for me
I think when you have a goal you need to look at for me
We have a goal you look to your schedule
You have a goal say I want to be you know, Sean. I want to be the world's greatest rapper great
Let's look at your schedule
How much time I spent rapping right? Like if you're not rapping every day, you're not gonna get there
So what's in your schedule has to help you go and get the goal that you want
If you have your goal and your schedule doesn't help you get those things, you're not gonna get that goal. You just talking right?
so
Remember going like a Tony Robbins event
Unleash the power within in California, everybody's getting rrragh, which is great. Like I love to when we've collab with his team
But for me, as soon as I learned something it goes right to the schedule. Like how do I put this in my schedule?
So it's a regular habit cuz otherwise just motivation and that's gone the next week when you come back home with floor
This is why I think five-year goals suck
so I'm walking to
Five your little side. That's all that's gonna make you Instagram, right? No contacts five-year goals suck every time when
I'm walking to a coffee shop two weeks ago and on the way
I've been thinking about Danny Brahimi to video guys and they talked me how much they love travelling Nina loves travelling for me
It's okay. Like I've traveled so much
The best part is this to be honest
Like I'd rather spend all day meeting with local entrepreneurs then seeing a bridge or a park or whatever, right?
Like this is the thing for me
so I just decided I
Want to visit with Nina because she loves traveling
Every city in Canada in the US that has a million people plus in the area. I
Just decided
We had a long weekend coming up. So Monday's a holiday for us. It's our Independence Day - July 1st
you guys have to like fourth and
I said, okay. What's the closest city that we can get to that? We hadn't been to Boston?
Great. We're gonna Boston Nina. Should we bring Danny? Brahim? So yeah, I invite them. I want to be on the channel more. Okay
The any Bri humor coming to God you want to come to Boston? Yep. Great. I
Put out some Instagram videos and newsletters and I find out Tony's in Boston
I didn't know that we just collabed on this video went live. His one-word video went live on my channel last week and
Tony's in Boston great. She live in contact on Twitter. She was in Boston. Awesome. KITT messages me
So hey, I got I got this awesome group Boston speaks
I can organize an event awesome like all this came together super quick
But it wasn't part of my 5-year plan right? I decided I want to do it. We had a long weekend coming up
Let's go to Boston
And now all of this is possible because of it and maybe I meet somebody here
Then changes the entire trajectory of what I end up doing
Right, but because we're so locked in on making our five-year plan happen
You're not open to the opportunity of something amazing happening to in your life
So there's a thing that we don't like been a recurring theme
Through the past like couple months for me is everything is the best?
Like when something goes wrong, it's the best
So we almost didn't put this on because because there's fire alarms that are being tested or something in the building or was or whatever
Like I want to do it with the fire alarms on like it's the best right like things never go according to plan
Right. And so when they don't go according to plan, that's the best then I want to do it even more
And I just trained myself that whenever something is not great. Like this is the best
Right and you lean in on it? Cuz because
Negativity is coming for you
You can't avoid it like even if you do zero with your life
There will be negative things that happen like people in your family will die and like lots of negativity will happen
So so what do you do when something negative comes for you? How do you react to it? Right there's nothing good nor bad
It's thinking that makes it so right you choose to react in the positive way. So when why'd she do this?
I had a workshop in Toronto in May and
We had two fire alarm go off and I ran down to the the secondary place. We're doing it
It's like guys it's the best I went to see everybody's like is the report now record with the alarm going off
This is amazing. Right and then and I have my dogs with me 24/7 and one of them is a puppy
She peed on the floor while I'm doing my speech like here
Right my puppies on my lab gets down pees on the floor and I just keep going that guy's the best, right?
Right like you just go with him then becomes a thing, right?
Where it's easy to get distracted
And it's not it's not the perfect ideal thing that you thought of and so now you can't post and you can't do the thing
That you want to do right you do it regardless like you do it and like that makes you stronger
When you do it when it's difficult
That's when it's awesome. If you're running the race against three-year-olds, you're gonna win every time you're gonna hate it
Nobody wants to run a race against three-year-olds, right? The challenges are where you grow
So when you feel a challenge and like this is the best jump in on it do it you have to do it
so I would have done it with I want the fire lamp like I want something to pull the fire line right now like it's
Awesome. It's the best
But if the power love went off and if there was a fire here right and like we're still staying here
We you know make it out. It would be like
the best story of all time
right
It's the best
Right, like we make it we can we can run pretty quickly to get the door, right?
But it's like a fire erupts and we all have to take off
I would still continue this Q&A on the streets while there's fire trucks and would be the best memory you guys would have
For the year, right? At least it would be for me
Well, then instance what was the worst-case scenario that you went into and then somehow you came out I
Have such a hard time thinking to negative spots
Like besides when you don't have when I was I'm trying to think of something recent. I
Don't know guys help me what was negative that we turned around to something
Yeah, I mean some of that's like way back like I didn't think that was the best but ultimately like
but but but but it has been like
that that is
For him to laughing
Bring him. Make sure you're not shaking the camera
That lesson taught me not to be a perfectionist
Because I was I had to have the perfect plan have a perfect pitch perfect plan and I never I never kickstart
I never never give it the push and I lost a 40 million dollar deal that pisses me out and it's the best right like
It's the biggest lesson of all time the pain that I suffered as an entrepreneur
Making 390 bucks a month and feeling like a total loser and having no back is what fueled my entire channel
it's the best I
Had a biotech software company early-stage biotechs software and
There was a lot of consolidation happening in our industry and actually picked we're thinking who's gonna buy us and we picked the right
Industry of who would buy us
But we picked the wrong company and here's a lesson like whenever you're picking you think someone's gonna buy you out
It's never the number one player was gonna buy you
It's a number four player who wants to become the number one player, and that was our problem
we targeted it just made so much sense for how our
Software would fit with this number one player and everything would be integrated to be amazing
They just didn't care because of the number one player
It was a number four player who raised an 800 million dollar fund who was going to acquisition spree that we caught too late
We were targeting the wrong company
And we were we were at the end like it was us and our biggest competitor and we lost to our biggest competitor
So like we were number two, we were the bridesmaid, right?
Now
So I
Don't know. It's not the expression. There's a Canadian thing. It was a groomsman. We were the groomsmen. I don't wanna get in trouble
And I just got my boss and ain't for everybody t-shirt
I want to be able to keep and not get kicked out of the city. We were the groomsmen
And it's not to say that we would have gotten a deal if we were more prepared
But we would have had at least a better shot
All right. So just the last time you learned another one like it's the best it's the best lesson
But it's a it's a that let that pain taught me that
If I ever want to get into an industry, and I want to make partnerships you want to target the aggressive number three
Four five six player. Not the number one. They don't they won't care about aggressive growth, right?
So if she's trying to sell her app who's gonna buy her app, it won't be the number one company
Yeah
Yeah, hopefully
right, and if not
Then then you'll eat the lesson in yourself and right but that's that's the goal right like and that was my pain
So I want to make it easier for the next gen right whatever your pain is
You can now make you tell your story
Some people will listen some people won't but you're trying at least and making the impact through your message
You know
I think for me if you know the thing that you need to do then like I secretly want you to leave right now and
Go film your video and maybe come back if we're still here, right?
I don't have a group. I mean for me I just wanna I'm here for you
Like I love I want to help I have no agenda
I'm not trying to sell anything and there's no point that I need to talk about whatever whatever brings the most value to you guys
If it's this format continuing, it's great
If it's you want to work with yourselves in a group and I popped around and say hi
Awesome, like it doesn't matter to me. I'm turns of steam motivated
The three things that I come up with is one your big why like what?
Why why why do you do this thing? Like for me helping entrepreneurs is a super strong wine
So why do you do your thing?
that's the big why the little why is number two and the little why is sometimes the big wise so
When I come up and say I'm trying to solve the world's biggest problem, right like that's ridiculous
Sometimes you're big why is too big and you're scared of it like a little Who am I to go off and do this thing?
Right, but the little wise just remembering that you helped one person, right? So
For me. I just go to my YouTube and like you guys are all full of love and it's amazing
But when I was just getting started as a speaker
I would I would make a PowerPoint file of all the feedback that I got from people
And we just look at that every morning because I do a speech and people would love me and then I wake up the next
Day and like life sucks
Right, so just remembering
that you helped one person like you may not be anywhere close to what you want to do, but you helped one person and
That is awesome. And
Then the third thing is just having a routine that that gets you excited in the morning
Like what a reverse engineer saw whatever gets you motivated and feeling unstoppable. You've already felt that in the past
What led you to feel that and then put that into morning routine?
With us watching video reading the Booker or like doing yoga on the balcony with your cat in your arm or like whatever who cares
Like do the thing that does matter like it's about you being awesome doesn't matter with other people
Think about the thing that you need to do, right?
if you woke up and did the thing that made you feel unstoppable every day your life and one year would be totally different than
What it is right now the more you do the better, you'll get if you're posting six times a day on Instagram
You'll get better like you pay attention what people are responding to we're finding your own message. You will slowly get better
Stories, I do three to five a day
Again, you get I don't know what I'm doing. Oh that button. Okay. Great Oh,
Post that right? That's the best story ever. I love that story right? It's the best
Right. It's cuz because when you post something like that you post this thing that makes zero sense
You've just released a fear of posting like nobody cares that you posted it and you've just released a fear
It's amazing. We were filming the stories of the brahim in the car
and I was so upset about how many takes he was doing on these things that
We were going at the border. We were going over a speed bump and
I I sped up to go over the speed bump and then stopped hard and everybody's like wow
And like bring him you better post that post right now
I'm never gonna be in any of your posts ever again in history
Right because you need like I just post it just release the fear being perfect all the time
Right and the more you do the better you'll get so I would I would map to your ambition
I would think like what do you if you want to get better be with health stories?
quick videos then I would I wouldn't make as many as you put like I try to do five times a day and
Just slowly get better better better better better better. I decided to not live my life with regret
I'll tell in heard this story, but it's a dating story. So she
Anyway, I never told my friend Anita. Anyway, we'll tell it here we go. It's the best drink
When I was 19 in with the Paris and I
had my map out and I'm standing us at the Notre Dame Cathedral and a girl comes up to me in perfect French asking for
directions
And I'm like, not this. I'm an ass's girl that hey go for coffee or whatever
Why she asked me in perfect French how to get somewhere a railing
Anyway I chickened out right? I'm like I am too afraid I'm scared
I don't ask her she leaves. I take a picture of like I try to get a picture of her across the
Stream this before digital cell phones and digital cameras, right? So like it gets I'm 38, so
That's 20 years ago
The picture comes out I don't get her Jesus
Anyway, so, this is a picture of this french Riverside I
Take it
I blow it up and I put it on my wall
at home and every day I look at that picture as a reminder to not live with regret as
A reminder to tell myself that the next time I get faced with an opportunity
What was I so I was afraid of rejection
I was afraid of failure and I wanted to develop the mindset that I can deal with failure and rejection
I can't deal with not knowing I have to know and so I look at that picture every day. I didn't tell anybody
When people came into my room said, oh, yeah, that's a beautiful picture. Yeah. It's from my trip to France
Not that I'm looking at every day. It's like I will not live when regret
And then I got the opportunity to take my dream job
You know 80 hundred K a year traveling around the world the banking job
I thought I wanted versus the 300 L a month startup company, that'd be an owner in
And because I've been looking at that picture every day I cited you know what?
This startup may fail. It may not work. I can always go get another job. It may not be that job
It's a different job
But I cannot deal with not knowing I can deal with the company flaming out and crashing and burning
But I don't want to be ten years in some corporate job thinking what if I just tried that startup business
So that lesson is still how I filter a lot of my decisions
I don't want to live with regret and I make the future regret. So painful. I
imagine like
Whatever I'm afraid to do or I imagine just fifty years of like that thing would have been the best thing ever
Like if I'm nervous to come here like the Boston speaks saying would be the thing that just defined my career
Be like the best thing of all time and I missed it. I didn't do it because I was afraid
Right. I just I just pile on so much. Maybe I'm a masochist and like maybe this won't work for you
But I just pile on so much
future fear
So that the present fear of doing the thing, isn't that scary?
So it's like if you have a hangnail, it's really bugging you. It's like you punch yourself in the arm
You don't fear the hangnail anymore, right?
that's basically what I do if the hangnail of like coming here is scary then I'll just punch myself in the arm and just
Not doing it becomes just insanely scary for the next 50 years
So then I have to go up and do that thing
saya works for me you mean, uh that
That was the biggest one of the biggest things if just deciding not to live with regret
So I don't go to books what I'm struggling
I go to videos I make the videos that I need to to see
Even now I make the video like every video that I post on my channel. I've
By watch and I I've learned something from it. If I haven't learned something from it. I don't post it
So I still go to my channel selfishly for myself because I want to be around Elon Musk and Oprah and all these people
And so it's selfish for me and I share it and thankfully you guys love it too. So
That I can build business around there, which is awesome. We all win but I don't I don't go to books anymore. Really?
So I don't have ideas for you there
The first part was around Oh, what do you do when the public hates your thing and write
One like it's the best
Right - it's still
You now have to decide is it just that you suck right now and that it will get better
Right, like if you want to be a speaker
You will suck at the beginning but as you practice
You will get better and so is it is it worth it? Like is yours is your mission worth it?
Understand that all this pain and struggling and suffering is ultimately how you're gonna win
Because dealing with the haters will now
Allow you to help other people who are dealing with haters where if you succumb to it
You're gonna hate your life and help nobody
Right, so if that has to happen
Like if the path forward has to happen that mission is so important to you then all of these
struggles and insecurities and conquering them is
The best like that's how you're gonna win
You have to overcome those and then you be the shield for the people
Who are suffering those same things and you're gonna say I get it? I understand what you're dealing with hop on board
I'm gonna help you like you climb up a step when you you you put your hand down and pull somebody up
To join you right and that's that's what you just keep doing
You keep picking people and pulling them up to where you're at and the more you deal with these
Situations and struggles the higher you climb up with the steps and the people you can climb up to join you right?
It's just is that mission important enough to you?
If it's not then then quit immediately I move on to something else
but the fact that you are concerned about you're so concerned about the hate and the and what people are thinking means that you
Must do it just to release it
Right. I was at a
nail spa with my dancing team
Right Thailand dance company, too and we won a local competition
So I took I took them out to a nail spa
And I went with them and then one of the women joke like hey, haven't you gonna get your nails done?
and my instinct immediately was no that's stupid but
But why because I have meetings and I have I have speaking gigs. I'm making YouTube videos
I can't go out with nail polish on it's ridiculous
But because that was the reason I had to do it
The only acceptable reason is I don't express myself through nail polish, which is why I don't have it on now
right
But because I was worried about the judgment of meeting these people
And doing videos and speaking gigs then I had to do it
And so I did it and I painted my nails full orange and then realize wow, these don't look good
So so then I put a white racing stripe across all of them, right?
and so and then I wore that's how that's why I walked out and then as I started chipping off I
Kept it on because that was the next level people looked at it and said your nails are
Gross
Right, you need to you need to you need to especially the women like you need to remove that and like like because of that
Judgement, that's why I'm doing it. Right. I love it. I want to eat that judgment
And now I don't need to like I can wear nail polish and it's not a thing
But I don't that's not how I express myself so I don't do it anymore
But when you're feeling the hate and the judgment for me
at least
It's a path that I need to go off and do that thing just to release that demon so that you don't care about those
People's opinions anymore, and then you can teach other people how to do it, too
So the most rewarding thing is just knowing that the work that I do matters. It's this like it's meeting you guys as helping entrepreneurs
Feeling like I do something today that meant something to help other people
You know, I think humans are built to serve and so it's what I try to do every day
I don't always do the best job, but I try
In terms of uncomfortableness. Yeah
Even now like even having these camera guys on me
One of the things with my channels I've known I've always historically hid behind like I'm most known for the top ten rules, right?
It's not even me and I get a lot of like what kids said. Hey, I wish you were more in the
Content and I'm trying to figure out ways to do that. Right like we're recording this today, you know, we'll see how it goes
I think there's a lot that I bring when I help people one on one that never gets documented and recorded
So that's part of that's uncomfortable for me. It's what I'm starting to share
So some of it is planning it's like, okay
I need to break out of my shell more and like make some more content and we'll see where it goes and
Some of it is just in the moment like getting hit with the nail polish
The thing is that for that is this the awareness because it's easy to say no that's stupid for the nail polish
But why is it stupid?
Right, and the only acceptable answer is I don't express myself to nail polish
But the real reason was I'm just afraid and a lot of the times the reason why you don't do something we will logically come
Up with something to say here's why I'm not doing it and it make total sense
And this you know the smarter you are the better the reasons you have for not doing something, right?
But the only real reason is that deep down behind you're afraid and that is not an acceptable reason. How would you say listen?
I know we've gotten some good energy here in the room
And and hopefully you guys met some new people here too if I've given anything to you
I think the most important thing is take that energy and do something with it today
No matter how small like that one thing that you guys were yelling out or in the back your head like try to find one
Thing to do today, even if it feels stupid
ridiculous tiny small like I'm gonna make a video great like just go make a one-minute Instagram video feel awkward and terrible and just
totally embarrassed and ashamed and then press post like
There you go
There we go. See
On here. He said do the video. This is it we're doing it live. Okay. So here we go
What do we what are we talking about?
He is the mascot for our books, yeah
So I have a family that's crazy about stuffed animals and they're the reason I actually did this
So most adults would hold him and do exactly weird with the wings, right?
I feel like as soon as I hold him. I want to flap the wings
I feel like this needs this guy needs to be a cartoon character and he like flies off and says something. Yeah
or like have a little thing at the back that I can like pull down and it makes it flap that be I know it's
Next-level expensive but but even this this is great hunter the owl
So if I've given you a name like do that and but but
But do it on you and and it's likely gonna suck and that's the best
Right no
but like everywhere this like just do it on you like go out and do the thing whether it's recording a video or making a
Phone call or asking that guy out or whatever like just do it
And and if you get rejected, it's awesome because it's not about the result
it's about the fact that you did you did something to get out of your funk and you're just
Constant life and say I'm gonna shoot for something bigger whether you hit it or not. The first time doesn't matter
It's the fact that you're shooting and you're shooting every day. You're gonna hit eventually and that's the process
Altruistic world domination honey Empire right? I'm grateful
I understand why I'm here I think because I am so open I wanted to think and see it's a bloody brief life
All of you have the potential for
enormous
success if you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others know about
Empire building that most people miss check out the link in the description for a free bonus video